foreign
have you read the real Anthony fauci by
Robert Kennedy Jr if so what are your
thoughts could things really be as bad
and corrupt as the book claims thank you
yes I have yes Brett has could things
really be as bad and corrupt as the book
claims I'm afraid so
um
I
was that it was a tough book to read
really really hard and one of the things
I did as I read it was just spot checked
the references it is incredibly well
referenced as anyone who's held the book
in their hands now as if you just listen
to it you don't necessarily know that
but if you have it in your hands it's
typeset in a way that's in like it's
actually a little hard to read because
it's so jam-packed like the margins are
tiny and it's just so jam-packed with
references so I
didn't look at even one in 25 of those
references but every now and again I
would look at one that struck me as
unusual or unlikely or I tried I did
occasionally do a haphazard like I'm
just gonna okay let's check this one and
see if it is what what he claims
um and I didn't doing that which was
again haphazard I didn't find any errors
right so it's incredibly well referenced
in a haphazard assessment of the
references that back up the claims that
he makes
were valid
it is an extraordinary
um
what's the opposite of vindication
indictment indictment it's an
extraordinary indictment of uh much of
the modern medical and public health and
pharmaceutical system the likes about
which we've been talking for two and a
half years and about which many people
uh besides Robert Kennedy Jr have been
talking about and uh I have also the
Silence with which the book was met was
remarkable I haven't heard anyone
uh contest anything in the book probably
there probably some of that exists but I
haven't seen it and certainly uh what
seemed to be the response
may be organized maybe not was ignore
this it will go away
um the other thing to say is if you look
at what we actually do understand what
the evidence actually suggests about our
coveted response it is the inverse of
the right response
the inverse is a very unlikely thing to
settle upon unless complete corruption
is the explanation
right it is possible to get a random
response through incompetence it is not
possible to get the inverse of a good
response and so
the
per the portrait payment
by the book is consistent
with a system that misled I mean in the
U.S A system that misled 300 million
people about the right way to respond to
this virus and the nature of the virus
and so anyway that kind of check also
suggests a very dire situation yep
that's that's all that's all true I will
say it's been a while
and I have notes I'm not going to go
into them now but there are a couple of
points one of the middling one of them
small uh or I thought it wasn't quite
right
um but having they were not on primary
points of of the book and again I was
reading it with his critical and I as I
as I as I could it's very long it's very
dense uh but I think uh
I think maybe one was the
characterization of The Germ theory of
disease which I just didn't find quite
uh as as
careful as it might have been but I
think that was the that was the larger
of the two and again it was just a
characterization of uh a way of
approaching how we understand uh
medicine and science rather than a claim
of fact none of the claims of fact that
I that I tried to fact check proved to
be wrong
I cannot recall there was one
bit in it that I thought was slightly uh
was beyond what the evidence actually
suggested okay um and
yeah it's been it's been some months at
this point yeah I can't quite put it
back together
um but let's just say the book is so
encyclopedic that the idea you know oh
it has an error and it's got a claim
that's too strong how could it not right
like that that's not there's no excuse
but like you know a book this
comprehensive and that had to have been
written so quickly yeah is is going to
have some places that are not quite a
perfect match given how much is in it
the uh the fact that it almost entirely
checks out is really quite extraordinary
yeah
[Music]
thank you